new at six thank you that is the message
from the lvcv after a report showed new
pre-pandemic record numbers of tourists
visiting las vegas
3.3 million visitors just in the month
of march so this comes as national
travel and tourism week is underway
christian casadas joining us now live
near las vegas boulevard with more on
why las vegas remains a top travel
destination christian
well guys i mean there are really so
many reasons why people want to come to
las vegas but for example the lvcva says
it's all about the experience now when
you mix the properties the restaurants
the nightlife and even the growing list
of residencies well that is exactly what
tourists say keeps them coming back the
24 hour sequence there's always
something to do 24 hours
and there's always something to do in
every hotel matthew and annette are
excited to leave the bronx behind and
get to las vegas i love las vegas it's
one it's mother's day weekend so my mom
is actually with me and it's our
anniversary this couple rolling into
town on scooters to get the most of
their stay you know you're walking in
this heat you're carrying luggage and
gear
now we're heading to old vegas right now
so we'll be there in an hour on our
scooters as tourists begin to pack the
strip the las vegas convention and
visitors authority is celebrating
national travel and tourism week they
say now is the best time to be in las
vegas here at the convention center we
have more shows on the books in 2022
than we did in 2019
however i'll couch that with
attendance is still down international
travel which makes up 15 percent of
overall visitation still not back even
after reid international restored 16
international locations but the future
is bright as proven by las vegas
celebrating a massive achievement the
nfl has never awarded one city its three
marquis events vegas hosted the pro bowl
earlier this year just came off of a
successful nfl draft and we have the
super bowl on the horizon for this
couple las vegas represents an endless
adventure of fun because the plan she
says is simple it's like your must-do
thing when you come to vegas
follow her around
good answer
all right so back out here live the lv
c-v-a also thanking the more than 165
000 hospitality workers all around the
valley for their efforts every single
day now on top of the daily events here
in las vegas we can't forget that
there's just so much excitement still
coming our way we can't forget that we
have the super bowl and of course
formula one christian casada is live
local now